welcome to be worse choice yeah first of
all I would like to introduce myself
it's my first lecture here so my name is
Peppa cuenca i am anna spanish
grandmaster and i'm really glad to be
here with all of you and i would like to
invite you to participate during the
class so you have questions comments
whatever don't hesitate to ask
so the class will be more fun so yes
we're gonna start analyzing my game from
da beat or david yeah I hope we can
learn all something from me all right so
why 24 and d5 everybody knows this
defense right the Scandinavian opening
and okay it's not very trendy among top
players but I used to have his time and
okay so normally white takes from d5 and
Knight f6 it's also possible to take of
course with the Queen but 96 also
perfectly playable so you want to
capture in d5 with your knight and then
try to develop your pieces for example
Knight takes d5 and then g6 Bishop g7
sure Castle and here there are different
alternatives for white so in this case
the white went for Knight c3 very normal
move and here Knight takes e5 and next
move Knight takes e5 what do you guys
think about this capture on d5 not so
good right it helps black developing
your pieces right so after Queen takes
e5 the Queen is perfectly played on the
center and now normally after Knight f3
blacks plan are like something like
knack c6 Bishop g4 and long Castle
followed by e5 and look at this Queen is
perfectly played on d5 right okay so
white plate Knight f3 knight c6 as I
told you aiming for this plan and here
b3
yeah this move is not so good right of
course white wants to maybe develop this
Bishop by a b2 in order to put it in the
best they're gonna but you're not
controlling the center with this b3
another idea is to go pick up c4
right in order to win a temple but black
here place the natural move Bishop f5
developing a PS attack in situ so really
natural move and at this point white
plays Bishop c4 what do you guys think
about this move what should black play
here okay Queenie for something else
Queenie for it's good yeah in the game
black played Queen D 6 by 24 just winds
up on straight away right so after Queen
e2 let's say just Queen c2 there's no
trouble at all for example sure castles
is six and then you want to go long
castle here and black is fine right
there's no way of tracking sorry of
attacking the screen on c2 so the bishop
hasn't got any square room B 2 or a 3 ok
but instead black played Queen d6
and white went for d3 what do you think
about this move
okay c3 is weak but most important what
happens with this bishop so yeah it's
kind of trapped right so you cannot
retreat that bishop imagine at some
point black goes a six and B five this
Bishop is kind of trap so normally you
want to have some squares to to go back
with your Bishop so and this is a really
important moment so when you play this
kind of moves some themes appear in the
position so black could immediately win
the game at this point pretty strange
but something comes to your mind it's
not that easy but given the fact that
white hasn't gone sure Castle and then I
have given you this hint that the bishop
hasn't got squares I ain't got enough
squares what will you play with black
here in this position some suggestions
there in the back b5 right that's very
good because if you play something like
a six you know that you go for b5 then I
don't know I can do whatever i can play
d4 for example then i have squares for
my bishop
but after b5 black would be winning
straight away right the point is you
don't have enough squares for your
bishop you got to take and then Queen
before check after Queen before check
let's say Bishop d2 and then Queen b5
black is a PS app so that's why you
always have to think really carefully
about all these moves d3 this Bishop
hasn't got any room and then after b5
white would have to resign okay
in the game black didn't go for b5 and
black played a five okay that's normal
move controlling the center and here
white went sure castles and here long
castle by black okay first question that
comes to my mind is can I take on f7 or
not will be a great move to take an f7
with my bishop it's just a bad move
it's interesting but and then for
example Daniel what do you think okay
that's pretty good
okay so Bishop f7 is actually big
mistake because of Queen f6 it's not
that clear we have to show the whole
line but the idea is as Danny says after
Bishop c4 Daisy for with a double attack
to the rook on a1 and to the knight on
f3 still white could play Bishop g5 here
in this position and after Queen g6
Bishop takes d8 it takes a three Queen
takes f3 and Knight takes the egg so
this means that black has to piece for a
rock which is normally good in middle
game positions
alright so Bishop f7 not very good what
do you think what would you play with
white here in this position no problem
what comes to your mind yeah yeah like
which which square like Queen eat or
okay Queenie - that's a decent move okay
you try to connect your rooks and then
you want to develop your Bishop on c1
then alright you can bring the loop to
the center etc etc but okay you always
have to pay attention to the pieces that
are not defended we said Bishop f7 it's
a blunder but we can play for example
Knight g5 and then Knight f7 is a huge
trade right so for example what will you
play here with black something like
Bishop g6 and then I guess I can just
take with my bishop right so it's not
the same if you take now with your
bishop then there's this fork with the
knight attacking the rook and the Queen
and why what is my trip much better
sorry
efore straightaway okay
what's your idea yeah yeah yeah I guess
I can just take on g6 and then after
queen g6 I can just take on e4 and then
look at this Knight it's so beautiful so
no point can kick this neck back so it's
a beautiful night on the center so 95
was really good at this point but
instead Bishop g5 was played in this
game so yeah exactly black place f6 and
then you don't have the witness anymore
and then you are winning a tempo by
attacking the bishop on g5 so clearly
Bishop g5 is a big mistake because you
are helping black with the development
no witness anymore on f7 and then where
would you retreat your bishop now - III
- D - 284 sir
what do you think in this position what
would you play with with the white
pieces
to eight four all right that's a
possibility the thing is now black can't
start a huge attack on the keen side you
are helping black in his development so
for example now g5 is actually pretty
strong you are giving black too many
Tempe actually one plant for black could
be to play f6 and g5 and after playing
Bishop t5 you are helping back so much
that now you wasted some so much time so
for example I guess okay 95 is the best
move here but another move like Bishop
e3 or something like this would be
interesting so just developing a piece
the point is after Bishop g5 f6 Bishop
84 now boom a g5 Bishop g3 and the next
move for black is more or less clear
right 85
what are you threatening with 85 in this
position for example the beginner you
wanted to go in the next movie you were
blacking in this position you want it to
go you want to go g4 or
8 for h4 right and h4 and then you will
be trapping this Bishop on g3 so this is
black spread you want to go 84 so
basically White has two options of
saving the bishop right so one is a tree
in order to get the h2 square for the
bishop and the earliest age for in the
game white played a trick and now there
were different alternatives for black in
this position to continue the attack so
one was 84 in the game black played g4
but it for it's perfectly natural
so after Bishop g2 how would you
continue the attack here
g4 exactly pretty good so you're opening
the G file that's pretty important the
the white skin is on the G file so you
want to open the G file and then puts on
route there in the future right and then
attack the g2 pump right and the white
is gonna suffer a lot look at this skin
on c8 it's perfectly safe and then the
skin on G on g1 is exposed because the G
file is open so white could be in
trouble in this position okay in the
game black went g4 straight away which
makes a lot of sense since sorry black
wants to open the H file which is also
very very dangerous for white so let's
say H takes e4 h takes e4 and Knight h4
alright so black is sorry white is stuck
in the fi bishop so black player went to
d7 natural move retreating the bishop
protecting the g4 pawn right so you
don't want to go for example 287 right
this would run into queen takes e4 check
and then that's upon app for white so
Bishop d7 natural move and Knight g6 was
played broke eight six nine takes f8
rook takes a fate and what do you think
blacks gonna play in the next move is
you allow him to do so for example in
the back f5 yeah but you see that H file
is quite open right
can you imagine here like if you had a
queen on h1 would be made right so what
would you play f5 is really interesting
you want to continue your attack you
want to play fi f4 but you had one move
here or two moves exactly Dennis yeah
Luke fh8 and then rook h1 checkmate
right so blacks plan is pretty simple
you just want to double the rooks on the
H file and get checkmate on the game
let me just all right
f3 was played
so basically white wants to escape by f2
and now what do you think what should
pluck hip what should black play here
yeah exactly that was a really beautiful
move by David our user from the YouTube
channel so the idea is if white captures
the Queen then you play rook fh8 and
then now there is not this f2 square for
the King to escape and then it's just
unstoppable rook h1 right so after g3
white played Queen e2 and then now rook
f h8 and then checkmate in the next move
so it was brilliant how he finished the
game after three Queen c5 and then G 3
really beautiful okay in the game there
were some mistakes for example this was
the most important moment after d3 like
you always have to pay attention to the
positions like for example if a bishop
can't retreat something smelling bad
yeah so there are not so many squares
for the bishop so just this move was
winning as as we explained in the game
b5 Bishop b5 and Queen before check King
in the center bishop without so many
squares something smells bad
alright so this was the first game now
we're gonna take a look on a crazy game
so d4 Knight f6 c4 e 5 Budapest gambit
yeah really aggressive gambit so you
give up this pawn in the center
I'm blacks idea ok you can play 94 but
94 is more common basically what you
want to do is place an active night
g4 and then you have weakened this
diagonal where you want to place at your
Bishop do you want to place your Bishop
on c5 and then attack this week f2 pawn
right so this is the so-called budapest
gambit anyway it's not so trendy I'm on
top players but among Club players is
one of the favorite openings and I've
seen very beautiful games with this with
this gambit
okay so Knight e3 was played in this
game really natural move developing a
piece defending your if iPhone and here
Bishop c5 so what's your name then what
would you play here with with web pieces
then there is only one good move perfect
so f2 is attack you don't have a natural
way to defend it just to play III right
so any other move would run into Bishop
f2 or 9f2 and then you will have to
resign so III very natural move and
Nexus 6 black wants to recapture on e5
I'm basically white can't do anything
about this so you want to insist and to
defend your if I phoned you will have to
play something like Queen d5 and then
after Queen e7 then there's no way of
stopping black from capturing on e5
right so that's why after night c6 white
continued with the development which
would be to and black to connie 598 c5
Knight c3 developing minor pieces short
castle short Castle Knight takes f3
Bishop takes a three and 95 on the back
what would you play here with the white
pieces Bishop e2 and what do you guys
think about this move b3 queen of 6 ok
that's interesting you can take the
bishop that's a point so the bishop pair
is extremely important in the middle
game so it's like a small victory for
black already to have the bishop pair so
you've got the bishop pair for nothing
so black is
okay Oh a little bit better but it's
sorry yeah okay
you wanted to go after be 305 right
sorry let me just go again
so you wanted to go after B 3 a 5 Ruki 8
yeah but the thing is you can take the
bishop on f3 so if you get the bishop
pair for free so there's no reason not
to do it but okay why knew about this he
care about bishop pair so and he went BB
to that
okay now you defend the c4 pawn and you
conserved your bishop pair so it's
actually a great choice by white and
here
Ruki ape was played a 3 and now Carla's
moved a 5 of course white wants to go
before and then to kick this bishop from
the c5 which is a very interesting
square you are putting some pressure
along this diagonal but a5 is a
brilliant move it's very typical in this
in these types of positions because what
are you doing with this a5 move what's
the idea behind a 5 yeah
okay you want to go a four and then
transfer your night
sorry a four and then transfer your
night to be three right yeah but that's
really hard to to make right because
after a four white can simply take your
pawn on e4 and then you need like one
two three moves to to bring your Knight
to b3 and even if you managed to do so
it's not the end of the world for y so
a5 mainly stops before and there is a
beautiful move in the budapest gambit
which is Dru k-6 and grew Kate six
followed by Queen h4 and then attack on
the Kings side that was when I remember
when I was a kid this was one of my
favorite maneuvers in chess you can
never imagine that this rook on eight on
a 8 is going to be attacking
white-skinned on the kingside from 86
right and then when the Queen comes to
h4 and then upon on d6 it's gonna be
really hard for for white to stop blacks
attack because whenever you play a3 this
Bishop can do a fantastic job on a tree
you can sacrifice that guy and then
white is going to suffer a lot okay so
white played b3 also to stop your idea
what's your name sorry Ali
okay so b3 also it's interesting because
whenever black wants to go sorry if at
some point black could play even with a
bishop on on d7 if black wants to go a 4
you can always reply with b4 so b3 is is
interesting also in that sense and then
of course white wants to develop this
bishop by a B - right so it's the only
natural diagonal that you can use in
this position and actually this bishop
is quite strong in this iona so ruk a6
was played by our italian loser i think
he was Italian and then Knight d5 95 the
knight controls important squares and
here the most natural move would be just
to go
just to go ruk eight-six following our
beautiful plan but instead black went
Queen h4 and now what would you play
with the white pieces here sorry 83 you
mean yeah
83 it's a possibility what else comes to
your mind okay the first move you have
to analyze what it is the Queen went
from da to 84 now it's not defending
something that used to defend before 90
x e7 is the first move that you have to
take in account if it works you in the
game because there is a fork attack in
two rooks and then if you win a rook or
an exchange and upon them clearly you're
going to win the game but of course this
is really really hard now because what
do you play with the black pieces Luke 8
6 exactly Luke 8 6 8 3 and now
when you play with the with the black
pieces d6 exactly sacrificing a whole
rook
so after 98
for example route g6 it's very
interesting you are taking on h3 with
your queen and for example let's say f4
what would you play here okay you're
gonna look down but all your pieces are
coordinating extremely well against the
skin so what do you play
Carla exactly I always say that to solve
any tactical puzzle you have to - taken
account their forcing moves captures
checks and threats if you do that you
will solve a lot of puzzles and then in
my next lectures and we're gonna use
that method the forcing moves and then
it's just just step by step and then
after five minutes you find a solution
so here rook g2 is the first forcing
move and after king taxi - now for
example bishop a tree
there's no good square for the king if
the King goes to G 1 then Queen g3
followed by Queen G to mate so the King
has to go to the H file let's say
something like keen H one and then
Bishop F 1 check King G 2 and for
example I don't know Bishop g3 and
there's no way of stopping Queen g3 and
Queen d2 so that's why it's not easy to
take on c7 instead white played g3 here
in this position and of course black
when Queen 83 right so now root 8 6 it's
even more dangerous because the queen is
going to come to H 2 and then the end of
the world so basically this is the so
called prophylaxis method so you want to
stop your opponent's plan
so we know that our opponents plans to
bring the route 286 so what would you
play to stop that yeah II for if or
risky though because this Bishop now is
stronger now you see that he is pointing
to this F to point straight away and
looks really dangerous but at least you
stop this route from coming to 86 which
was a killing move at this point all
right d6 was possible but our friend
from Italy
he played group d6 what are you
threatening with this route d6 move yeah
c6 perfect so if white goes something
like I don't know
a4 right let's say something stupid a4
c6 would just win in the spot right so
you can't retreat this night because
there is a pin and then why do have to
resign all right so why after group d6
he played before attacking this bishop
and the game at this point becomes
completely crazy I even I had some
trouble analyzing this game I wasn't
with my chess board and then I couldn't
understand anything but suddenly the
moves had some reason behind so black
player played route e to e6 really
beautiful move sacrificing another piece
okay let's just check it out so you want
to go rookie 6 here yeah okay I think I
found the solution what do you what do
you guys think what would you play here
with the white pieces yeah of course if
I can move twice then I will play rook
eight six and then white will have to
resign straightaway exactly ninety four
does a killing move there is a fork so
exactly so rube the six before and now
Luke et6
it's David no no no no this is an
Italian user from San Luis chess club
YouTube channel but he is playing quite
interesting yeah yeah yeah
and then of course now it's not that
easy to play this Knight f4 ideas
because there is a pin here and if you
take the bishop then the next move is
ruk h6 sacrifice in another exchange but
the thing is after Bishop takes rook
takes nobody can stop not even LeBron
James can stop Queen takes h2 right so
Bishop h5 would be the only try but
after rook takes Age 5 why do you have
to resign okay so white player was a
tough guy and then he played Bishop h5
right away very interesting because if
now you play rook eight six what happens
in the position so let's say black
plague stroke eight six yeah
yeah Bishop h6 rook takes exactly
neither for whoo-wee rook disappeared
Knight f4 and then this Queen is almost
trapped right so there's no square for
this Queen my twins on the spot
okay so Bishop h5 really interesting
move
so now black says you know now I don't
want to lose my Bishop on c5 so I'll
just move it to d4 very interesting
because now if you take this Bishop on
d4 then Queen age five and then I'm
threatening to go c6 and then Knight f3
also with this killing fork so after
Bishop d4y 20k - and black plate the
beautiful group g6 did you play Knight
f4 here in this position let's just try
to think all together the first move
that comes to my mind is Bishop F to
check Bishop f2 key nf2 and then there
is the intermediate move Queen h2 and
then you're going to capture this screen
and black is winning sorry Bishop a1 now
F for Bishop a1 that's also interesting
that's also interesting but I guess I
have Queen d6 another intermediate move
let's say rook d6 and I retreat
Queen where
Queen f1 yeah kim taek's
and rook the sex yeah that also wins
very good okay so you kind of plain RF
for different reasons which way one and
a bishop f2 all seem to work so that's
why white played grew K 2 and here rook
g6 crazy game and now what is white
sorry black threatening can you take the
rook on d6 of course that's a first we
have to analyze right put why Knight g4
boom right and if I could play a three
and protect this h2 point with my rook
would be very nice but this bishop on d4
is doing a fantastic job and then you
can you can move your F pawn right so
you can't take the rook on g6
so what's black thread what what happens
if you play if white plays Queen e2 for
example just a random of rook g3
beautiful move rook takes pawn takes
Queen takes again this Bishop the big
fish so keen h1 and Queen a tree
something like rook g6 check it's a
killing move again if Bishop takes
Knight f3 or even H takes g6 or swimming
because you can never play F 3 and then
Knight of 3/8 unstoppable again so he's
playing extremely creatively in this
game so white played teenage one
brilliant move again so prophylaxis
against rook takes c3 and here black
went for rook takes d5 sacrificing an
exchange in order to bring this bishop
from CA to life see txt 5 and d6
okay again
can't you take this bishop on g6 why
Bishop g4 okay but now remember Mikey
Nissan h1 what would you play here with
the white pieces f3 same idea if you go
after Bishop takes c6 Knight g4 right
that would be more natural but again f3
saves the day for for the white for the
white player so why I can't take on g6
or can I take on g6 why not a free
beautiful move winning on the spot you
threaten checkmate on h2 only move for
white is Queen takes a three right and
then Queen f1 checkmate so a lot of
themes in this position so after d6
basically white is aiming to bring the
bishop to the action let's say some
Bishop g4 or so nag to g4 so at this
point again same same idea okay if you
take on d4 with the Queen then Queen f1
so you can never take the best move in
this position was f4 still was a
complicated position after Bishop g4 but
why decided to go for Bishop f4 really
natural move do you want to exchange
some pieces on e5 and then you are
developing another piece and at this
point black plate rook f6
okay rook f6 probably the best move here
for white is just to take on e5 and
let's say D takes e5 and then F for
something like this still not clear
right just an extreme down but looks
like white is this in good shape instead
white played Bishop e2 retreating the
bishop now that Bishop finished the job
on h5 since drew K chicks not it's not a
threat anymore
but here another brilliant move by the
black player Pope move comes to your
mind here Bishop g4 okay if you play
Bishop g4 I guess I can just play a3
same idea it's a brilliant move
brilliant so I was thinking is this guy
magnus carlsen
instead of italian user from the YouTube
channel yeah look at four okay and then
Knight g4 you said I guess the same
stuff all the time I can take everything
and player three right
so the move is g5 amazing move what are
you threatening with g5 of course the
bishop on f4 yes that all we can see but
we are threatening to go rook h6 again
the thing is what happens if white takes
on g5
any ideas so let's put it in the in the
board we should take g5
Bishop f2 all right so what happens if I
just take your rook yeah you could go
something like Bishop g3 but then Bishop
f3 for example and then same stuff this
troop defending the h2 point so no not
working Bishop f2 another idea Daniel
it's a very difficult movement it's it's
really beautiful maybe he's coming for
the championship downside okay
the movies rook f3 okay let's try to
understand this move first of all you
are threatening Knight g4 yeah you have
threatened in 94 in the next move
so if Y does nothing 90 foreign Queen is
to me and if white takes on f3 what
would you play dr. Ali
just just try to give me checkmate in
two moves and then it will work out if
you had two moves what would you play
checkmate in two but you can move twice
okay and then there's another square for
the night instead of g4 now takes a
three that's the move because the only
way to stop the mate on h2 is to take on
it on their three and that will run into
queen f1 alright so this was the game it
was a fantastic game okay very shaky so
many mistakes but it's natural to make
mistakes in these types of positions but
very interesting ideas by the black
player and also white player was a tough
defender so the game finished like that
it should be to g5 takes rook f3 Bishop
takes okay the game they play d4 but
then after Knight g4 wide resigned
because okay Bishop f4 was played and
broke f2 and yeah you have threatening
like hundreds of checkmates like Queen H
2 followed by rook F 2 sorry rook h2 or
Queen G 2 etc and then white had to
resign
okay so I'm going to show you another
game the third game and this comes with
a message it says dear st. Louis chess
club my name is Fabian otay otay
I don't know how to pronounce that my
German is really bad okay and I live in
Germany for four years so I am German 20
years old and my national rating is
about 12:40 I haven't played that much
chess though I'd like to submit the
chest calm correspondence game that I
want with the black pieces in our Kings
Indian defense despite winning I'm not
sure if I played the late opening and
early middle game correctly I will be
very much appreciative if a GM could
analyze this game so let's go over Kings
Indian one of my favorite openings I
have played the King's Indian my whole
life it's a lot of fun so d4 c4
j6 Knight c3 and here you can choose
between the Kings Indian and the groom
field yeah the groom fell is after d5
the Kings Indian Bishop g7 and then II
for you concede the center and then you
try to to strike on the center right so
if for d6 f3 you know how this is called
the sammich Sameach system against the
Kings indium very interesting so it's a
very aggressive opening you want to
place your Bishop um III your queen on
d2 and then maybe you want to start some
sort of attack on the King side against
black skin or maybe it's sometimes you
want to develop this night by ie2 or
even with this Knight comes to d7 this
night it's perfectly played on f2 that's
why develop this night by a h3 and then
F - it's very very interesting
ok so III sure castles and Bishop d3
Bishop d3 is not the main move normally
people here play as I told you [ __ ] of
III or Bishop g5 followed by Queen d2
but ok Bishop d3 a natural move just
developing a piece now white wants to
finish developing by playing Knight G to
e2 and then short castle right black
plate a5 and then at this position what
do you play with the white pieces for
example what's your name aaseesh okay H
what would you play with the white
pieces here
d5 what do you think about D takes e5 ok
very good
there are more reasons first of all if
you have space you don't want to give up
the center yeah you want to close it for
example like d5 is the most natural move
second reason you take on e5 now d4 is
going to be a weak square for the whole
game before is very very weak and then
d5 is not because you can play always c6
in order to kick some piece from there
but if a night ends on d4 nopon can't
keep that piece from there right so d4
is extremely weak and then after you
have played f3 all these dark squares
are extremely weak and then some piece
can potentially end up in c5 and
d4 and then this is not a good business
for y so that's why I detect if I first
big mistake
positional mistake in the middle game so
DTX e5t takes e5 Bishop e3 and then
knight c6 really natural move you want
to go to the width square right - to d4
a3 a3 white wants to go b4 and try to to
create some counter play on the key
inside sorry on the Queen side a5 I'm
stopping them b3 and Bishop e6 natural
move developing your pieces and group B
1 was played in order to go b4 now how
would you continue here in this position
with the working with the black pieces
sir Sir what would you play here with
the black places that's really natural
move yeah occupying the wick square
there are other options for example
every King junior player knows that the
F pawn at some point has to be in the
action right so normally you want to
remove this night from f6 and then push
f5 right what's the best square for this
knight on f6 you want to go to d7 you
want to go to ei to h5 to g4 you want to
capture on e4 yeah I love this move
Knight h5 it's really active so in many
cases you are also threatening to go on
Queen h4 check and then as you said the
f4 square is really tasty so for example
imagine 92 you can't even play ignite f4
because when this day I wanna open for
this Bishop it can be gonna kill him
Bishop so for example let's say Knight
f4 he takes up 4 black is already women
there is a double attack to these 2
pieces and then the only move that
defend both your blunder in another one
the bishop on d3 so 95 was the best move
in the position and also you are
supporting the wake square by another
piece the bishop on g7 so now you can
play 94 comfortably
sorry yeah
g3 here yeah sorry yeah g3 of course
that's very typical reaction against
this 9h 5 ideas but I guess you can just
play f5 here this position and then look
at this skin side it's not developed and
then you have f4 ideas the night is
coming to d4 potential threats on the f3
square once you have developed your
Knight to e2 so I guess this is really
bad position for white instead he went
498 it's also interesting but more
passive right we like to have our knight
in an active square like h5 and then
would be much better but ok 98
interesting move white when 92 e2 and f5
and again that's another important point
of the game in this position white went
Queen c2 what do you think about this
movie what will you play with the white
pieces here for example Karla
you just Castle yeah that's the most
natural move I would say but then black
plays just so automatic it's so easy to
go f/4g 585 g4 and checkmating tip moves
yeah it's okay not that easy yeah but
your your play is very simple g5 h 5g
for Queen g5 and suddenly a lot of
travel for white yes exactly that's
typical reaction you take on f5 and then
you castle
and then if black wants to go f4 it you
will have a lot of weak squares and this
Bishop on d3 will become a monster and
also you will have this important square
on e4 for your minor pieces right so
that's why it takes e5 was necessary in
this position but instead white went
Queen c2 Queen c2 here and of course now
black close the position with f4 f4
Bishop f2 okay now it's another
important moment of the game what would
you play with black here yeah this is a
difficult position yeah because the
first thought that comes to our minds is
I wanna attack ya when I go g5 h 5 and
g4 but is that make sense without
without the white player having Castle
so if you go g5 h 583 then if you go G 4
now white is going to be attacking you
on the H file and the white king is more
or less safe only one so g5 h 5 is this
is actually what happened in the game
but it's not so precise I would say can
you force the white came to Castle or
not
exactly 25 is very good move because
you're forcing this came to come here
of course if g3q just take and then take
on f3 and then you are just opponent
right but there are only two natural
moves one is short castle and then is
keen f1 so let's say if you go short
castle
you can even now retreat your queen and
then start your attack or even after
keen f1 I would say the best move is
just Queen D 8 and then g5 + h5 now it
makes a lot of sense that the king can't
can't escape from the king side
okay in the game King h8 was played
Knight d5 and g5 starting this attack
which is not so effective now a3 and h5
as I told you now to play d4 it's gonna
be very hard for black after H takes you
can't even take you can't even recapture
with the H point since there is opinion
on the H file right so not a brilliant
idea - to play g4 without white player
having castle so Queen c3 was played and
now what will you play with the black
pieces
you you want to exchange this bishop
okay he you would love to trade these
two guys yeah but sounds like difficult
at least yeah to bring this Bishop to c5
maybe they would have captured all your
queenside meanwhile okay keen 87 yeah so
you want to bring the King to g6 or
something like this to g8 yeah
actually 94 was possible
Nagbe fourth straight away it was a an
interesting move in this position 94 it
looks like you are losing upon right but
the point is after takes takes takes a
c6 and 97 and this Knight is trap look
at this Knight no a square for for
tonight okay even though you are
capturing this night the position is not
that is it because white would have a
strong center with some points but okay
94 was maybe the best move in this
position because in the game is you know
play Knight d4 there's no a clear plan
for for black right since you cannot
play your automatic moves like g4
another story would be with this key and
castle yeah that would be almost a black
victory after g4 Queen g5 but now the
skin is only one extremely safe so b6
was played in the game and now b4 sorry
bishop c2 native 6 + b4 was the best
move here just continuing attacking on
the Queen side and then it's not clear
what blacks gonna do I would say that
white is better at this point you can
have a cut from d5 because of the CTX e5
there is a lot of pressure on the Queen
side
and but instead white went G for what do
you think about this move you'll like it
why exactly you shouldn't touch anything
on the kingside right because the only
way to proceed for black is to play t4
and then it's just not possible because
after eight stakes there is this pin so
b4 was more reasonable okay but g4 was
played and then yeah you say it's not a
good move but what should what what
would you play here with the black
pieces you want to put do you want to
close with h4 when you want to take on
g4 or ampersand exactly I'm person F
takes G 3 and suddenly black has some
play on the key inside right we should
take c3 and night h7 was played okay
h4 let's say for example bishop h2 + 9
h5 yeah this is also interesting yet
definitely sorry yeah ok here maybe we
should be 5 but that's too risky because
of the Knight takes e5 Queen takes e5 I
don't know
Knight takes d5 queenie 693 looks very
dangerous for white let's say this
position queen is 693 you are attacking
this guy you're attacking on f3 and then
the dark squares are extremely weak for
whites only this is the keenest still on
the center I would say this is clear
advantage for black but ok so Bishop h2
for example it's not that clear yeah in
the game there were two options night at
7 or 97 I prefer actually 97 makes more
sense you protect the e5 pawn and then
you you can also jump to c5 a more
active square
okay but in the game nine eight seven
white plate age four and what do we play
with the black pieces here yeah
g-force burger g4
you don't want to open the H file and
then look at this skin now extremely
unsafe or do you want right
this smells too bad for y so we got this
brilliant square for us the D for
squared the F file is gonna get open and
here white player blundered so now I'm
gonna ask you to find the move that
loses in one in one move sorry
we take c5 you know he'll play that but
then he went for f4 and forth and now
for example what would you play yes
if I were okay we can move twice I will
play f5 not legal so black wins just
have to find how exactly yeah
so the first moves you have to take in
account always are the captures yeah is
there is something that you can capture
you have to take to take a look on that
yeah so the captures here possible
possible the possible captures in this
position our queen takes h4 which is not
very good right Bishop takes d5 it's a
reasonable move but also it takes a four
and then you realize that there's a
double attack on the Queen and on the
bishop right you see so now you will
have to move the Queen let's say to d2
for example and then it takes g3 and
then white resigns it's just a piece off
for black okay the game continued
something like Queen d3f take c3 Knight
takes g3 and 95 and other piece is
coming to f3 Queen III and rook f3
attacking the Queen on the night
Queen to g1
and Knight f6 Bishop d1 which uptakes
Misha takes and now what do you play
exactly Knight a free fork to the Queen
and the king and black Queens
alright so ask him the question from the
user he was asking if he played well the
middle game I would say he played really
well so he occupied the wake square on
d4 he stopped white pawn march on the
Queen side and then he started an attack
on the key inside by playing 98
I would have preferred 9h 5 because he's
a much more active square but in general
he played a good game
okay so this was everything I had
prepared for for today's class WS choice
hope you enjoy it and see you in the
next class about chess in the Romantic
era here in Valentine's Day so not a bad
day for this thank you
[Music]